so JT brown who seems to me to be a
quantum field theorists or string
theorist asked two questions what one
whether constructive field theory could
be useful in establishing whether the
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
quantum field theories could be used in
help constructing string or membrane
theory and the answer to that I think is
that it's not really needed since the at
least in two dimensions the
two-dimensional field theories we use to
understand the nature of perturbative
string theory them worldsheet theories
we use to describe the perturbative
expansions of string scattering
amplitudes are largely based on soluble
two-dimensional field theories ones
which are much simpler than the general
class of that constructive field theory
sometimes can prove exist but can't
solve what we really need to formulate
those perturbative rules and string
theory are soluble two-dimensional field
theories as far as three-dimensional
field theories go that might describe
membranes and people have been trying
for decades to construct to solve in in
order to have a description of what's
called M theory in which the basic
objects are not strings but membranes so
far that's eluded our understanding
completely it's hard to imagine that the
old-fashioned constructive field theory
methods will prove useful since those
have had a lot of problems dealing with
theories with extra symmetry even gauge
theories
and the kinds of super symmetric
three-dimensional field theories one
would need the described membranes
wouldn't really fit in to the kind of
theories that constructive field theory
have been useful for as far as four
dimensions go JD Braun asks whether it
is possible that four dimensional
quantum field theory doesn't exist and
that four dimensional yang-mills is an
approximation to the fields living on
the world sheet of a fundamental theory
in lower dimensions well first of all
four dimensional quantum field theory we
believe does exist there's no rigorous
mathematical proof of that but the
theories we use in the standard model
and certainly especially QCD which is a
asymptotically free theory surely do
exist physicists are totally convinced
of that and in fact a supersymmetric
version of qcd which is finite and
conformally invariant not only exists
but we now suspect is soluble at least
in the limit of large and large number
of colors and may even have already been
solved so I don't think we need to
resort to the imaginative idea that that
Brown suggests for describing
consistently four-dimensional gauge
there is